as the first true stand-alone story in
the Star Wars saga there was a whole lot
riding on rogue one throughout the story
surrounding the film is almost as
interesting as the one we watched on the
big screen from axed cameos for the
film's humble beginnings there's a whole
lot more to rogue one and just Jin's
quest has snagged the Death Star plans
so let's dig into the untold truth of
rogue one unexpected origins the entire
concept for Rover one came from two
sentences in the New Hope's opening
crawl but it was a visual effects
supervisor for the special edition to
add the bright idea to turn those lines
into a full-fledged movie effects guru
John Knoll came up with the page when
Lucasfilm wanted to do a live-action
Star Wars series the idea was shelved
when Disney bought the franchise and
announced new plan for these standalone
stories no run the idea passed his
colleagues and the blockbuster was born
so at least something good came of those
special editions and despite the fact
that the entire movie is based on an
opening crawl it doesn't have one itself
leaping right into the action but it
turns out the first draft of the film
actually did have a crawl until director
Gareth Edwards decided to remove it
that's because rogue one delves into the
battle reference and the introduction to
a new hope
the creative team worried it would be a
bit redundant to have an opening crawl
for events already recapped in another
one a collage of other movies the film's
editors revealed that the film was
sketched out with an unusual approach
instead of working off a script they cut
footage from hundreds of other movies to
follow the scene-by-scene story
breakdown in order to figure out exactly
how much dialogue the film would
actually need this approach also helped
them figure out how long different
sequences would take so they could hash
out a more detailed script on the
surface it feels like a backwards way to
make a movie but it works out pretty
well now we just like to get our hands
on that maka Brio trailer tribulations
rogue ones reshoots have been reported
exhaustively I've seen by scene
breakdowns of everything that was left
out of the final cut of the film and
it's now obvious entire subplots would
end up on the cutting room floor why did
all those early scenes remain in the
trailers in the weeks and months leading
up to release long after it was obvious
that never be in the final cut according
to Edwards there was a decision made on
the marketing side because the folks
cutting those commercials and trailers
felt they did a good job of selling the
spirit of the film regardless of the
final film story now or never nerve a
phase ensure it was supposed to kiss
don't blame me
Alan Tudyk and his cut cameo this one
gets a little messy so just bear with us
Alan Tudyk played the fan favorite droid
k2s oh and the war a motion capture rig
to bring him to life but he also popped
up as a pilot in a scene that didn't
make it into the final film the weird
part
Dudek played the cameo role as ray
nearly from his hit web series con man
where he plays a self-deprecating sci-fi
actor bouncing between fan conventions
ray never has much luck keeping big
roles and it seems even his real-life
rogue one cameo couldn't survive our
fictional streak of fire breaks did you
know that wasn't me in terms of the
performance - dick was actually hired to
portray the snarky droid is around seven
feet tall and even though k2s Oh was
creative of motion capture and CGI they
still needed to dig to be around the
droids of proximate height while acting
with the rest of the cast
the solution was support - dick on
stilts which he wore for much of the
production it might sound like a hassle
but it sure beats having to wear an
entire c-3po costume like Anthony
Daniels did when the two actors met
Daniels have some choice words for -
dick he said wait a minute
are you wearing a actual robot costume
were they doing it motion capture I said
motion capture the you ha ha ha
everything old is new again Edwards
raided the vaults at Skywalker Ranch and
Lucasfilm and discovered unused footage
from the first Star Wars film keen-eyed
fans noticed some familiar faces during
Rowan's final battle that's because
Edwards painstakingly restored some
unused alternate shots of the pilots
during the rebels attack on the Death
Star in a new hope it's another for fans
but it's also one more subtle way that
rogue one enriches a faraway galaxy we
know and love that one of the only
genuinely vintage thing about the film
either to get the film to sync up with
the look of a new hope Edwards used a
vintage ultra Panavision 7 millimeter
lenses Quentin Tarantino unearthed at
Panavision for the filming of the
hateful eight and attach them to an
ultra high-tech 6k large former camera
it proved a perfect combination
of lo-fi and high-tech and allowed
Edwards to strike the same balance that
made the original trilogy look so
memorable a new composer along with
being the first time the lone Star Wars
film rogue one also marked the end of an
era for franchise composer John Williams
who has scored every film in the series
over the decades this time around
Edwards opted to bring in Michael
taquinho who scored films like The
Incredibles the new Star Trek franchise
and Doctor Strange to provide the
soundtrack to Jin's adventure takeno
adds enough musical tributes that it
still feels like star wars while also
setting a different tone meanwhile
Williams etc terms represent eight and
nine so we'll get more old-school Star
Wars seems pretty soon Peter Jackson was
there he might be the mind behind one of
the biggest Jama franchises in history
but even Peter Jackson has to tip his
hat when Darth Vader's around the man
behind the Lord of the Rings and Hobbit
trilogy z-- happen to be in town when
Edwards was directing that epic closing
scene when Darth Vader goes berserk on
escaping rebel agents so Edwards gave
him a heads up to when he was filming
Jackson man over immediately to geek out
liver Vader mowing through a hallway of
soldiers famous director or not no one
complained Jackson for going full-on a
fanboy and basking in Vedas glory
[Music]
thanks for watching click the loop icon
for subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to